I'm taking this woman to head for awards
$10,000 that money's mine boys that is a
scene for Quentin Tarantino painful age
at Nichelle they've got Oscar hopes for
this one absolutely macy they sure do
you know they're rushing it into the
theaters on christmas day to meet the
deadline for Oscar consideration
Quentin's put together another killer
cast including Channing Tatum and I got
to talk to all of the big stars it's
like a weird western acid trip of the
game Clue one of them fellas it's not
what he says he is everyone's bad even
the good guy is bad Channing's role is
being kept a secret but I can tell you
the whole movie is Tarantino twisted
let's slow it down let's slow it way
down samuel l jackson is one of the
gun-slinging 8 with pistols pointed at
bounty hunter Kurt Russell and his
valuable catch Jennifer Jason Leigh
jennifer is the most hateful Jennifer's
definitely I think one of the baddest
like she's just bad so bad she's good
jennifer is up for Golden Globe so it's
quentin screenplay we're just waiting
for everybody go sleep assam i gotta
kill ya there is something to be said
for being the only female energy in that
whole group of men how did that work
first of all it's like dreamy and Ally
yeah there is it was the best group of
men ever after a while we give the guys
kind of way all kind of begin to realize
you know Jennifer's a girl you really
really think of that we don't really
think of that every but we should
consider it once in a while and then we
kind of look at each other one no we
shouldn't filming in the Colorado winter
was hard but it could pay off with award
show gold I both myself every year first
ballot you get is like pick the five
actors you think did a great job this
year so if i did five movies i put my
name in Best Actor five times you know
it's like
Sam Jackson Sam Jackson always keeping
it ahead loving you know there's a point
in this movie that makes you sit up and
say oh my god Jennifer Jason Leigh this
lady's crazy now you can see it right